yeah look i think the thing about this
this photograph is that what we should
be clear about this is a party that the
met are not investigating so sue grey
just to recap because there's a lot
happened sue gray was charged with
looking at events in number 10 during
lockdowns she passed her evidence to the
met
the met said now we have seen this
evidence we now think there are a dozen
events at number 10 that pass the
threshold for police investigation and
this party uh this event this zoom quiz
was not was not one of them okay so just
to be clear people might be surprised by
that photo but in met terms that in
their view was not something that was an
egregious breach
of the rules the prime minister clear
that that was
a zoom
quiz and people were isolated in
different rooms make of that what you
will but that that's their argument um i
think the more interesting thing about
this is that the met also said at the
time there are over 300 photos that have
been sent to the met so there must be
lots and lots of photos of different
events that the meta now investigating
none of which have yet come out and
interestingly dominic cummings who we
know
is not the prime minister's biggest fan
if to put it mildly uh tweeted out as
that photo landed there are way better
pictures than that floating around
including in the flat the met are
investigating an alleged party in the
prime minister's flat in downing street
on november the 13th and the big
question jade is i think when mps
because they were not then the phones
all came out and they were looking at
this photo
i imagine for mps what they'll be
thinking about now conservative mps is
what sort of other photos could come out
that could be potentially very very
incriminating for the prime minister or
not but the question is there are lots
of them
that the met now have in their
possession that have been investigated